all right let's do this uh we would
normally now jump to super chats but i
want to do one more segment because i've
been sitting on the story and it's a
week old now but i really want to talk
about it
it has very little to do with politics
and everything to do with just the
absurdity of the
modern political world ladies and
gentlemen
vanderbilt players were crying during
sarah fuller's
30-yard kick this is an actual news
story let me break it down for you
sarah fuller is the first woman to play
and what is it power five i think it's
called
i'm not a big football fan so i don't
know a whole lot about what this means
changing the game
sarah fuller became the first woman to
play in a power five college football
game
the team she's on vanderbilt lost
41-0 she came out in the second half and
did uh
she kicked and kicked like between 20
and 30 yards
and then they ended up losing i tweeted
about this and i didn't say anything
negative because i was just like i was
like his
history was made for uh you know the
first woman to play in a power five game
loses 41 to zero she kicked 30 yards
and people were trying to convince me
like say to me she
she was it was a squib kick it was on
purpose right
then we got then we got more news this
is the craziest thing
vanderbilt players consider opting out a
final game at georgia
another kicker joining team after this
fiasco
players actually said that they wouldn't
play
in another game they were not going to
do it seems like
i don't know if this team thought hey
we'll just put the first female kick
around to get all this good social
justice pr
but it resulted in the players actually
crying so this is the story from the
daily caller they say
vanderbilt players were apparently
emotional during sarah fuller's kick
against missouri okay
maybe they were crying because with
tears of joy right they were just crying
watching this historic moment
sure during the 41-0 blowout loss
fuller became the first woman to play in
a major college football game
when she kicked the start of the second
half the ball went a staggering 30 yards
there were some people on the sideline
tearing up quarterback mike wright said
during a game
during it during a saturday morning
college game day segment on fuller's
kick
as hard as that might be to believe i
can promise that i'm not making this up
you can watch the video below
it used to be an insult yadda yadda when
is this nonsense going to end they say
this is nothing more than a pr stunt
which didn't save derek mason's job
and now we're out here talking about
players crying are you kidding me
this can't possibly be real from the way
people talk about fuller's kick you'd
think she was the first woman to walk on
the moon so it sounds like they're
actually saying they were crying tears
of joy
right yeah i mean it's it's incredibly
silly
and patronizing yes and i mean
any meaningful i don't know i mean
there's record low testosterone out
there
and it keeps going down remember the try
guys from buzzfeed yes
so so there were four guys at buzzfeed
and they got their t
levels tested and they were all as
like 80 year old men i could have told
you that just looking at them though
super low and it's kind of it's kind of
crazy i wonder is there like
what's going on there's been a
progressive decline in testosterone
that's been tested
throughout the decades there's many
theories out there there's many
different explanations some people are
talking about microplastics some people
are talking about poor diet some people
are talking about birth control in the
water birth control in the water which
is another thing some people are talking
about the frogs
deciding to change their orientation
turn the freaking frog
i didn't want to say that but yes that's
exactly what's been happening so there's
many different is that gonna de-rank you
they're gonna think it was actually alex
jones they're gonna be like we caught it
did somebody just like
no no i'm just doing it in person but
this is a serious issue because
reproductivity of human beings is going
down dramatically so people
uh well so what does that have to do
with the the kick in the well we just
made a comment about the testosterone
issue and maybe they were crying for
real
because they no i feel emotional when i
read that i thought they were crying
because like their careers are now
destroyed yeah
they're now losers on a losing team
because of this pr stunt woman
they lost one to two maybe you're not
familiar with this like there was a
some chicago white sox owner who had his
team
like send out a six-year-old or
something the bat in the in a baseball
game
really he walked because the small
strike zone
is that real that's real like look at it
i think it's eddie geidell g-a-e-d-e-l
i think that's right but like i know the
owner is bill beck see if i can see if i
got the name right
that's amazing i always find the things
like eddie
look at that man my memory is good he
was he was uh the world's smallest
player
he was five foot six inches no no that's
rizzuto click on the click on the link
oh this eddie guydell
yeah there you go oh wow look at that
that's real
that happened oh wow but he wasn't six
years old was that i'm not sure how old
he was when he played he's just a little
person
no no he was a child he was a child he
was a child he gained recognition
in the second game of st louis brown's
double header weighing 60 pounds and
staying at three foot seven inches
he became the shortest player in history
of the major leagues oh no you're right
i guess i guess you're right he was
actually he looks like a child yeah
smart play though
smart player tiny strike zone hard to
hard to get that he's gonna in he walks
yeah he he walks uh so okay so that's
what i didn't remember correctly so what
what is the
strategic advantage of having a female
kicker there there isn't one but i
guess that's not buzzfeed's gonna like
you i was i was thinking it's like you
know 50 years ago people recognize this
sort of thing as like a ridiculous stun
and it's like well i'm gonna tell you
i'm gonna tell you the reason i want to
talk about this is because i said
i think like three years ago when like a
lot of video game and movie stuff was
happening
i said it's only a matter of time before
they just change the rules to mandate
women in major league sports
like why not the rules are arbitrary
right we could we could we could raise
the basketball uh
uh nets five feet we'd just agree to do
it then no more dunking or something
right people might still be able to dunk
i guess
but we could just say okay new world
changed so what if right now everyone
just said okay new rule change
players have to be half women half men
why not
well um is the nba gonna be diverse
then you just see a bunch of i mean
there would be a huge market
for uh trans women yep well i i said
back then
it's only a matter of time before there
are diversity demands in major league
sports
if the rules can be changed by people
then there's no reason they can't have a
rule saying
the easiest way to get women in major
league sports is just to mandate that
they're there
it's it's same as any diversity quota
it's not about your your merit it's
about
making sure there's representation in
the game right i mean
you know i would have i would have said
democrats wouldn't do that but they've
done a lot of crazy things in the past
few years
but this already happens in mainstream
society in the corporate world this
already exists so why wouldn't it exist
in the mba
and and i think it's going to it's
absolutely going to
get their bones broken well perhaps
or perhaps you're a bigot ian
struck by the fact that he's not
recognizing the impact of discourse on
physiology
well no no but think about this think
about this the
there's no rule stopping women from
playing in any major league sport
they just don't ever win when they try
out they like you know she kicked 30
yards
she didn't kick 70. i was so i looked i
don't know anything about football and
they said a good a good you know kick is
70 yards
she might have been kicking on side
because they were down so far was that
the case
yeah well down 25 points at the
beginning of the second
half and she might take it on sidekick
and some people said it was a squib kick
intentionally
which is an on-site yeah yeah she might
be a great kicker yeah
for a woman but so the point i'm making
is look
we make up the rules of the game right
now the rules are the best of the best
are chosen by the managers and the
and on the owners for who's gonna be on
the team we could simply just say yeah
exactly
so diversity over meritocracy as men are
losing testosterone are women getting
more beastly
i don't know well i don't know about
naturally like men are naturally losing
testosterone yeah like the the buzzfeed
guys are a good example of that
but i think that might be because
they're not exercising yeah it's really
you know look guys used to have to go
and chop lumber true now they sit at
their desks and eat doritos and drink
mountain dew
you know it was not good for my
waistline that's right
but uh maybe maybe with more women
getting in in sports and things like
that maybe we'll see an increase over
time
but uh look the point i'm saying is you
mentioned in corporations we already
have the diversity quotas you look at
california now they passed that law
where they got to me
yeah mandatory board member must be like
female or you know
you know minority or whatever why not in
major league sports
i'm not saying i'm not saying why not in
the sense of i'm advocating for it i'm
saying
why wouldn't they do it they will be
doing it and you're calling it out and
we're going to see in a few months maybe
you know even a few years
just these kind of people rising
representation
of here we are it's like all these
people are all the same everyone gets an
award i don't know i mean you might
end up it just it might be a bridge too
far right like you you get the sense
that people were able to do a lot of
things
like i want you to think about this like
i wonder how long the mass kneeling
would have lasted in a world where every
the crowds were still at the arenas
right after george floyd there's a sense
where they could get away with it
because there was no audience to boo i
wonder how long people would do that if
there was systematic doing
well look what happened to the nba in
their record low ratings with them
politicizing this and literally putting
black lives matter on the basketball
court and then they polled people it was
a hill harris
x and they found that most people said i
can't stand the politics
yeah so they're not watching anymore
well i watched one game and it was just
during the timeouts during the
interviews any kind of
patronizing any kind of virtual signal
they could put out they put out there as
much as they could so
what you're saying i think is going to
come true it's only going to be a matter
of time
and uh it's trendy it's cool will you
got to get with the times
yeah that's why i'm a conservative
it's going to come down to uh clapter
right what we're going to see is people
are going to be watching sports and
they're not going to care about
touchdowns
or scores they're going to care about
representation of people so
it's like that episode of south park
where they had sarcastical where
football was too rough so then it turned
into a game of tag and then it was like
them chasing balloons around and
wearing bras and it was because randy
was like okay
fine like it's too rough why don't we
just have the kids chase balloons
instead i guess
and they're like okay that's a good idea
oh okay then why not have them wear bras
while they do it and they're like
okay let's do it and they did it and the
game became just ridiculous nonsense
and then they didn't realize like they
were like i don't know if i'm being
sarcastic anymore nothing makes sense
everything's broken
but i think i think that's where we're
gonna we're gonna get to we're going to
start seeing a bunch of these
you know political if you did if you had
like a force
fed men and women on its football field
together
you'd eventually get like a group of
rogue dudes that are huge and beast
that would just go start their own
league i think you know you know what i
i i was reading that we should just let
everybody take whatever drugs they want
in terms of performing enhancements just
kidding and just who joe rogan talking
about this summer
probably where they were like just let
everybody take whatever drugs they want
and then you'll have gigantic monsters
just running on the field
steroids yeah just everything just you
know their heart rate's like 250 resting
and they're like
running you know 30 miles an hour just
just the craziest
all out barry bonds was roided out a lot
seriously we just didn't know about it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time